prima di iniziare questo video volevo
dirvi che il ricavato di questo video
più una parte che aggiungerò io verrà
donata in beneficenza all'associazione
dimensione animale rho c'è stato da poco
un incendio nel loro gattile purtroppo
ha distrutto non rifugge hanno
ovviamente urgente bisogno di donazioni
per ricostruire le cattive e riprendere
appunto a salvare i gatti poi avevano
che dei cani sono stata una tragedia
sicuramente molto molto duro per i
volontari che che lavoravano appunto
negativa il pezzo che si ha accesso
aiutarli vi lascio comunque linking
descrizione se volete vedere il loro
sito se volete sapere di chi lo storico
è successo oggi purtroppo all'improvviso
il racconto senza un po su instagram o
nella top community mano tutti seguono
su instagram
non tutti hanno instagram apple e può
anche avere un modo di ricordarmi di
pippo allora imprese un piccolo e il mio
cazzo da del cian di un gatto
meraviglioso gioco stava male e oggi
artica ieri gli hanno fatto le analisi
del sangue
il veterinario che le ha dato più di ciò
che delle medicine e quindi insomma
speriamo che serve ripreso stiamo
aspettando di analisi del sangue ma è
morto quel che è rimasto sopra nostra
come morrone animale o una persona
purtroppo quando solo dicono sistemare
ma se proprio non riesce a metabolizzare
la razione di rifiuti di crederci e non
vuoi greci e non vuole accettare
sì più che altro perché è stato così
inaspettato è comunque più brava 10 anni
e quindi abbiamo un altro gatto il sogno
che ne ha 18 19 quindi non mi sarei mai
aspettata una morte così improvvisa da
tempo comunque il risultato di analisi
sono arrivati e aveva un insufficienza
renale e ho letto che è molto difficile
che si salvino meno che non viene
scoperto molto prima troppo interesse
più garantista il sale e volevo punto
per questo video per come
per vedere dei video suoi subito delle
di video suoi così che anche voi
possiate conoscerlo è che piatto
speciale che era a volevo anche dire che
comunque le cure di analisi tutto sono
state abbastanza costose lì anche per
aiutare punto di vaccini che non possono
permettersi queste cure è giusto fare
beneficenza non solo per gli animali
ovviamente ci sono tantissime cause per
cui è giusto fare beneficenza in questo
caso questa mi sembrava più appropriata
andiamo a vedere dei video ovviamente
sarà difficile per me perché non riesco
a capacitarmi del fatto che non possono
più piccola rlo infetto per noi per la
famiglia anche era legato più speciale
che avesse mai conosciuto perché era un
caso veramente super emotivo dolcissimo
che ti guardava si sapeva ascoltare o
affezionatissimo mio padre stavano
sempre insieme veramente uno speciale
che non mi aspettavo proprio
beh certo mancare così all'improvviso
con come mi dicevo voglio far conoscere
anche d'annunzio in più
tramite il video appunto perché mi
facevo un sacco di video che occhi
scritta quando la tv sembra che sto
pensato di bonomi interrompere umana
assumerà tutti io la mia forse quando
farlo obbligati il mio
l'altro aveva gli occhi un po
particolari con questo prova che possono
sempre essere giusta e 1 sgozzato il
musetto augurano che sembra triste muse
che si sa chi la voleva dare alla del
fuoco quindi era un po le scatole sempre
[Musica]
che bello
secondo mia colpa tifosi quasi mai
nocivo insomma 20.08 spazio con mio
padre contempo erano veramente e che se
la canta la trovo una cosa sono
dall'anno scorso però sembra un gatto
piccolo non è che me la faccio
spacciatrice sempre arrabbiato un peso
del secondo
[Musica]
sì
no
come lava scampare che se togliete il
veggente normale a riscattare le carezze
allora siccome ragazzo sensibile ma che
si forma di pupazzo a forma di gatto
guardate come reagisce sempre questi
lascino in pace
mangia che il padre che la voleva
cercare la tv è povero ma chi è vicino
un altro assieme a migliorarmi altro
gatto è piccolina erano super
affezionati anche loro dormivo assieme
stato sempre assieme città migliore tiga
temi specifici che tenere il film che la
linguetta nel quale 0
veramente comunicava così tanto sotto
gli occhi di rubio padre capito questa
volta mio padre stava per tris un altro
ragazzo 2003 in giappone mi mancava
molto evidenti come potete vedere perché
noi abbiamo fatto piacere conoscere il
tempo che non potrò più farlo cioccolami
mirko malissimo ma se avete perso un
animale o una persona capirete
soprattutto con rapporti della famiglia
non così perché gli animali diventano un
posto della famiglia volevo solamente
dirmi di stare vicino ai vostri animali
ha detto sono
bene che dà molto all'altro possono
succedere queste cose ti ritrovi lì
acuto impreparato e poi ti penti di aver
passato più tempo possibile con o quell
animale con quella persona quindi
pensati si sa come state spendendo il
vostro il tempo che ho letto ho letto i
vostri commenti su instagram youtube che
avete lasciato il posto appunto di
volevo ringraziare anch'io per tutte le
lore garini ad oggi avete scritto
appunto su questi posti grazie anche da
parte mia e tale mi ha sopportato
supportati supportato e tutto il giorno
considero piano piano di abituarmi lady
tecnico cascone di più spesso lo so che
ce lo dicano probabilmente perché
l'amore che provo per una città piccola
come sistema simile affettuoso e dolce
saprofiti capisce veramente ti guardo mi
parlò viti ascoltavo proprio comunque
proprio per mia poter piazzare
che fosse un po sapendo che preferisco
condividere un po tutto con voi non solo
nei momenti più felici perché la vita è
fatta di uniti felici di momenti tristi
di un t buy diluiti allegri quindi non
dovete pensare che dovete per forza
essere sempre felici qualsiasi cosa
accada è normale essere tristi o
sentirsi giovani non vi preoccupate non
pensate che quello che vedete su
internet perché vedete una persona
sempre costantemente allegra sempre
felice vuol dire che la loro vita è
sempre così siamo finiti in mani e non
dovete paragonare la vostra vita
qualcuno su internet pensando ad una
persona cose o è più felice perché è
sempre felice dei video nelle foto non è
così normale stare male intanto sentirsi
più essere tristi e comunque vi
ringrazio tantissimo come ha detto
aumentare tutte le cose carine insomma
che avevate scritto se volete fatemi
sapere nei commenti dei vostri animali
domestici che non ci sono più quelli che
avete ancora scrivetemi come si chiamano
quanti anni hanno che rimane è oppure se
avete persi come si chiamavano fatemi
sapere tutto nei commenti o comunque vi
ringrazio di cuore e ringrazio tanto
anche mio fratello
cisco che si è preso cura molto dipinto
è che mi aggiornato continuamente
poverino tempo è morto tra le sue mani
praticamente è stato bruttissimo da lui
è bruttissimo ovviamente ancora più
perché comunque sia lui che il tuo padre
stavano sempre vicino si scavi di questo
video androidi beneficenza opinioni
pubblicità che avete guardato in cui
avete cliccato e non c'ero io una parte
quindi vi ringrazio anche per aver
sostenuto questo video anche da questo
punto di vista è niente cercherò di
accettarlo che hanno piano piano piano
con il tempo diventa tutto più facile
vi mando un bacino enorme ciao